si vous circulez dans la grande région
de montréal je ne vous apprendrai rien
les chantiers se sont multipliés au
cours des dernières années en fait il ya
un rattrapage incroyable en raison des
années on n'a absolument rien fait mais
un coût à payer pour tout ça on a
demandé à françois cormier d'aller se
promener un peu et de faire un bilan
si c'est possible on l'écouté c'est
qu'il ya un véhicule qui a pris feu un
pc le chroniqueur à la circulation de
radio canada
d'année en année on lui redemande à quoi
s'attendre dans la région de montréal à
la rentrée des travaux qui s'en viennent
à l'automne c'est ça sera horrible
encore une fois si on pense aux travaux
dans l'échangeur turcot
il y en a pour une dizaine d'années le
constat est sans équivoque
l'échangeur turcot sera le méga-chantier
des sorties et certaines artères seront
fermés et tout près de l'échangeur
turcot le chantier bonaventure dont la
ville de montréal est maître d'oeuvre
ont défait l'autoroute en hauteur pour
la ramener au niveau du sol
les travaux en prévision du 375e
anniversaire de montréal des
célébrations dont l'impact se fait déjà
sentir
les deux prochaines années c'est un
grand blitz dur un répit pendant 2017
avec le 375e anniversaire de la ville de
montréal et après là on va reprendre
il n'ya d'ailleurs qu'à monter en
voiture et emprunté un trajet qui
normalement ne prend que quelques
minutes pour se heurter à une cascade de
sortie ferme et des tours après des
tours après des tours
c'est certain que cet automne on a
beaucoup chanté on parle depuis 420
chantiers pour l'année à venir montréal
c'est du jamais vu
le centre ville sera l'un des endroits
les plus chauds cet automne
l'administration coderre assure qu'elle
planifie adéquatement les travaux pour
minimiser leur impact
on va pas commencer côte des neiges
avant constat mengi pile il ya deux
différentes faces âge se fait en
concertation et en coordination le mot
clé c'est coordination et qu'en est il
de ces travaux qui durent des mois et
des mois comme par exemple coin papineau
et sherbrooke
on part d'une preuve des projets
intégrés
où on fait tous les travaux en même
temps on parle de gaz métropolitain le
service de l'eau là comme son service
électrique donc c'est plus important
mais là on a terminé pour une génération
mais il n'ya pas que les travaux il ya
aussi le nombre de véhicules qui a
augmenté considérablement entre 2009 et
sur l'île de montréal près de 31 mille
véhicules immatriculés de plus depuis
cinq ans à laval une hausse de 24 mille
dans lanaudière
36000 dans les laurentides quarante
mille et en montérégie
100000 véhicules de plus avec plus de
200 mille véhicules supplémentaires en
cinq ans c'est inévitable
la congestion ne peut que s'intensifier
car les jeunes sont rendus au cégep
universités ça leur prend note au fait
qu'on voit souvent deux trois quatre
véhicules par famille alors tout le
monde sera mars au même endroit il n'y a
pas de nouvelles structures de
construite depuis très longtemps sauf
peut-être le pont charbonneau le pont
qui relie laval à montréal dans l'est
mais à part ça ce sont les mêmes
infrastructures depuis 50 ans
que voulez vous des quarts et la
métropolitaine ça ne suffit plus pour
cette rentrée 2015
les autorités invitent donc les
automobilistes à consulter et tous les
sites internet applications sur
téléphones intelligents ou chroniqueur à
la circulation
les gens ont une empreinte dans les
transports en commun alors tout le monde
amène leur voiture en ville ça qui est
pas beaucoup d'heures la congestion et
oui pourquoi ne pas utiliser les
transports en commun dans lesquels on ne
sauve pas nécessairement de temps mais
où on fait notre part pour diminuer la
circulation routière